60 minutes plus is sharing the stories
of six people who say q anon damaged
their relationships with loved ones
these six strangers first connected on a
reddit forum called q anon casualties an
online community with more than 180 000
members 60 minutes plus correspondent
lori siegel spoke to the group about
their frustration and their sense of
loss at watching loved ones who they say
have fallen into a web of conspiracy
theories
how many of you have loved ones who
support q anon
how many of you have loved ones who
believe there's a global cabal of
liberal elite pedophiles who run a child
sex trafficking ring
it's pretty extraordinary
even saying those words out loud
what's even stranger is hearing them say
it
by now you've heard of the term q anon
the pro-trump web of conspiracy theories
that began as a fringe online movement
in 2017 but has since exploded
these six people sons daughters brothers
and partners
say they are bound by the loss of their
loved ones to cuenon there's almost a
lingo for what it is that you guys are
experiencing
cue siblings accused spouse
few parents what does it mean to have
q family
to not have them
they are lost to us
and we are clinging
for
the idea of
them without the cue
you guys are all in a sense united by
loss and grief but we're not talking
about death what's extraordinary is
we're talking about conspiracy
and and i think that they're very
similar
unfortunately
60 minutes plus correspondent and dot
dot dot media founder lori siegel joins
us now lori um you know these people are
grieving the loss of loved ones as if
they almost died but they're not dead um
what's this like for them i mean it's
just devastating right and you saw all
those people you can see the pain is
palpable i mean the stories are just so
tragic one of the women we spoke to when
you watch the piece you'll hear her
speak about how she before that she had
struggled with thoughts of suicide and
depression but she said her father saved
her life and now fast forward a year
later she says she can't even speak to
her father she had to cut him off for
mental health reasons another man says
he can't hold his girlfriend because
he's been vaccinated and she says he's
been jabbed she believes he's quote
shedding this is really because there is
a cover story in people magazine right
now about a father who everybody said
was normal devoted to his children who
killed his two young children
because he believed something about q
anon was affecting them how does this
happen to people who are seemingly so
normal so thoughtful and so smart i
think that's what a lot of folks were
struggling with right and i think there
are a lot of different factors right one
i would go ahead and say someone's
covered technology for a long time look
at the misinformation that's been going
online and that's been allowed to spread
online over the last couple of believe
in this information and people believe
it you click on one thing it serves you
up another thing now you add to this a
pandemic where people have been isolated
they're home they're looking for a
community
and and really this is what a lot of
this is this is a community so much soda
our experts are calling this a public
health crisis they see people are
self-radicalizing they say we need to
have education in schools about this we
need trusted voices to speak on it so in
the old days i mean a crazy person could
put a flyer under your windshield wiper
and you get it you ball it up because
it's done now the misinformation comes
much more quickly so is the answer for
tech companies to
take care of this i mean i think i think
they should have taken care of this a
long time ago i mean i remember the rise
of q on happened in 2017 facebook put an
emphasis on facebook groups to really
help build community what they didn't
realize at the time was they were
helping people behind closed internet
doors gather and they didn't crack down
on this
for years
but i think now as our experts are
saying looking at this is almost a
public health crisis where there's more
information on this there's more
educational tools one of our experts has
a site called antidote where people can
learn how to speak to their
relatives who have fallen into
conspiracy theories i think that's
something we've got to learn how to
grapple with because this is almost a
new normal it really is i can't wait to
see your report lori siegel thank you
very much as always you can watch lori's
full report q anon casualties right now
on 60 minutes plus on the viacom cbs
streaming service paramount plus